[Music]
[Applause]
oh look who has a documentary the guy
who never wanted to talk about himself
now has to talk about himself Barry
Sanders it's called bye-bye
Barry why did you do a
documentary what did I do a
documentary um actually the timing was
right Dan um you know I actually had
chance to talk about you know a lot of
other people um besides myself um you
know who who you know were important to
me um the good Folks at NFL films and
Prime
video um you know really want to get
behind this project um and uh for me it
was time to or for me you know I felt
like I had time to to just you know
really devote to it sit down and and
kind of and kind of try to tell my story
in in in a certain format so so um I
think all the right excuse me all the
right things just kind of came together
you know I I wrote a book in
2023 I'm sorry in 2003 2004 you know a
lot has happened since then um you know
but I think to answer your question
though I think just you know the timing
was right but you never wanted to talk
about
yourself that's true and I and and you
know if when you see the doc you'll see
that still you know Dad does most of the
talking
um he he always did he always did he
always did so he so even in this
documentary my my dad does most of the
talking and um you know so so um I just
have a I have a few parts here and there
well I remember when your dad said
you're no Jim Brown and and it and it
really hit me I'm like your son's pretty
good and you like that didn't you you
like that line from him didn't I did I
was like uh okay and I realized you were
never going to
be you know your dad's favorite running
back which is okay you know which is
okay but because even as a kid you know
he would always talk about Jim Brown um
you know and so and so from a very early
age I was I was programmed you know but
were you always trying to get your dad
just finally
say you know you're you're great or
you're you're my favorite running I
don't know if you were seeking dad's
approval on this
thing I don't think that ever even
crossed my mind honestly I I knew
that uh I I knew that I was at least one
of his
favorites what did you learn about you
in this
documentary what did I learn about me I
mean I don't I don't know that anything
just really really stands out um but
other people talking about you that
maybe you didn't realize how they felt
at the time or what they think now did
you your kids hey I didn't realize how
much you got on my case that um you know
draft day you were terrible that day you
were getting you were terrible I go out
there to cover the draft you get
selected I can't find you I'm out there
specifically to interview you and then I
have to tell ESPN they go uh I thought
you're friends with Barry I said uh so
did I I can't find
it and then I'm like I was kind of I was
mad at you I was like what are you doing
here hey look I was I was at home
waiting for an important phone call
man but once you got
drafted Oh yeah I don't even I don't
know once I got drafted um I'm sure I'm
sure it took me a while to get out of
the neighborhood oh stop stop who did
you think was going to draft
you
no I knew I knew that um or I had a good
idea um that the lions were going to
draft me um just because of
conversations that I had um with Coach
Bon beforehand um where he he explained
that yeah if I'm you know if I'm
available at at three or whatever um
then they they would pick me which you
know I mean you never know until it
actually happens you never know until it
actually happens but uh but that was my
so that was sort of my expectation going
into the draft the documentary is on
Prime video It's called bye-bye Barry
you lose that game your last game your
agent Peter schaer calls me and says you
can't use this information Barry is
going to get on a plane he's going to
London and he's going to
retire why London why did you need to
get out of Detroit get out of the
country
um well for me at the time it it just
seemed like a really good idea um I knew
that there would be some Fallout uh you
know and I had I had been to London
before um kind of knew how to get around
there um and so it was just kind of
getting getting away as far away from
everything as possible uh but still a
place where I was somewhat familiar with
um you know and so that was that was
really really the thinking it was you
know and and just to kind of I guess try
to
clear my head if that's the word or or
um you know just just to you know
because there was a pretty good there
was a pretty good Fallout um you know
and and so that's kind of what I was
thinking at that
time did you love
football are you serious yeah absolutely
I I I I think you love basketball I
think you were great at football and
then when you don't
win
then I mean you walked
away no I definitely love football I
mean you know maybe I I liked them
equally or um I certainly enjoyed
playing basketball as well you know in
my free time and even even as a player
in the NFL I played a lot of basketball
but but um but you know there're
certainly just different games um you
know in a lot of ways but but I think I
had great love for both of them but I
certainly love football and had a
passion for it um you know and I think
you know different when you when you do
it for a living um you know and you do
it as long as I did it um you know it it
does it can become um sort of um you
know sort of a different sort of
relationship with with the game but but
no I would definitely say I loved it um
and and even still enjoy it to this day
I mentioned I think it's in the
documentary that there's nobody I've
ever covered who's been like Barry and I
remember when you called me and said you
were getting a a new
car and do you remember this and uh you
you didn't want to get anything flashy
but you were worried this might be
flashy and you were getting a uh a Honda
four-door
Accord and you you said is that to fancy
I go no I think it's pretty good you
know I don't think that's too flashy
there I I don't remember that specific
conversation but um I did it was
actually a Acura own which is kind of a
Honda I I think that's the car you're
referring to um yeah that might be a
rich guy's Honda is the
Acura you plus when I went into your
house you had a couch and a TV and
nothing
else oh yeah I mean I was you you're
talking about you know days fresh out of
college so I was you know my Decor was
you know dressed up like the dorm
[Laughter]
room if you guys okay here's something I
know you told me a long time ago
that maybe if you could have played for
the
Raiders you would have continued to play
football remember saying that you grew
up a Raider fan yeah I mean I I
certainly grew up a big Raiders fan and
um I don't know once I got toward the
end of my career I don't know when I
when I told you that but that sounds
like something I would have said maybe
at the beginning or middle but I don't I
don't know that at the end of my career
I would have I would have uh felt the
same way I mean I don't I don't know I
don't I don't I mean they went to a
Super Bowl I guess a year or two after I
retired um you're the one that brought
it up because this was towards the end
of your career but was it yeah was there
any thought of you playing elsewhere at
the at the end of your
career no not not really that's not
that's not something I ever um insisted
on or had a conversation about um with
the team um so it it's not something
ever put any energy towards um but yeah
I mean I you know I definitely um I
could I could hear myself making that
statement but but um but no it's not
something I actually you know tried to
make happen what do you think of the
current
lines oh man guys look good man guys
look good guys uh you know I mean I
think this is what a lot of Detroit
Lions fans have been hoping for and
waiting for um I think you know a lot of
us really this season in particular knew
that this team um definitely had a
chance to win a division um to really do
what they've done um and be one of the
class uh one of one of the top teams in
the in the
NFC um you know you got your work cut
out for you obviously with uh with
Philadelphia you know with the Niners
with
Cowboys um even if there's a few others
in there um the Seahawks who whoever
else but but certainly the
lions are um at the top of the class at
this point um you know you look at the
kind of football they're playing um and
I think it's a it's certainly a recipe
for Success you look at the quarterback
play and you know the receivers um the
running backs um the defense you know
and you look at the strip the strip um
sack the end the game by Aiden
Hutchinson um on Sunday you know you win
a game where you turn the ball over a
lot um you know so I I think this team
is this team can go a long ways um you
know they stay healthy you know the the
kind of culture that Coach Campbell has
instilled kind of expectations and then
also the you know just the players that
he's been able to to to get in the
building um you know and and this team
this team I think is just getting
started uh take me back to when Joe
Montana's leaving San Francisco and he
wanted to play for the Lions because he
wanted to play on the same team as you
oh wow yeah well I mean you know coach
coach F tells the story that uh you know
that Joe caught him up um and he was
excited obviously uh and said you know
Joe said he wanted to come and play in
Detroit um this is obviously before he
as he was leaving the ners and before he
signed with the Chiefs um and uh coach
coach V took that word back to uh the
organization and I guess you know they
they they thought he Joe monana was too
old or whatever at that point and so the
deal didn't happen um I feel like I feel
like by the way his last one of his last
games regular season games with the
Niners was against the Lions and he and
he just tore us up he torched us um
Montana did um and uh but anyway so
obviously he goes on to the Chiefs and
and has uh couple great years there but
J wouldn't that have been something wow
wouldn't that have been
something yeah yeah
well maybe would have been a different
documentary
Absolut it would have maybe ended
differently than you you in London yeah
maybe so you get a guy like that in the
building no you get a guy like that in
the building obviously he was the
greatest um in a lot of our eyes and
certainly the greatest in that era so so
no yeah I mean but anyway it's it's
certainly just a great story that coach
F told and and um and you know and and
so really but you know what it
highlights though is that you know some
teams make great decisions you know and
on personnel and and what have you and
you see why they have success and and
you see why others
don't hope you're doing well uh hope the
family's good is you know I've hav't
seen the documentary I keep waiting for
Amazon to send it to me me is there any
footage of us playing
basketball um there's no footage of us
playing basketball but but um but you
definitely have um a good good piece of
uh of the film okay you know you're
you're featured in there for sure so
don't you know no fears there do I get
anything do I get is there
residuals am I getting paid and like if
there's Awards hey what am I get it's in
the mail man it's in the mail Ser okay
I'm going to believe you you wouldn't
lie to me would you no no hey no no it's
it's in the mail man I appreciate that
all right well good luck with well thank
you actually thank you for part of yeah
about time you got around just saying
something nice about me yeah
thank I'm always I'm always
complimenting you what do you mean when
who are you complimenting me too your
wife your kids no you don't no to the
world D said that I was his favorite
sports broadcaster though my dad said
that yeah yeah I was number
one oh oh yeah he said that right yeah
I'm sure I'm sure he did right right uh
exactly good luck with the documentary
great to talk to you again Barry hey Dan
appreciate it man thanks you for the
time that's Barry Sanders